welcome to this video playing Carol m2
from the Czech Republic no I don't think
so i wove a key i'm now sorry guys what
can i play here maybe maybe the
blumenfeld if he allows it always a
funny opening one of the better gambits
really i think wow never sons never seen
that one God maybe just just just push
ahead at least this bliss prevents 93 if
you take see can play Knight c3 maybe
but this is not not too bad should I
grab the center with d5 or just develop
probably probably both feasible I'm not
sure if d5 is so great here if we cancel
I'd squares considerably
you know now this looks like a decent
position get get good development and
what exactly is why it's plan he could I
was trying to save could play Bishop d6
but the gunite h5 failure is going to go
to III probably yeah that's does this
does not lead to much
okay just play play some slide improving
rules I don't know don't have a great
constructive plan at the moment not sure
how to set up the center if i should
play any move of the deep on we can see
six enormously or we see wants to
exchange some pieces okay well no no I
know I don't mind the trade now that's
ok that's ok probably even if five is
not not bad yeah this is not not so bad
I have fun ideas to regroup my night
towards deform and on Bishop g5 I can
lose the night away he does not want to
trade the dark squared Bishop intending
queen age three so
and now night see 726 maybe Bishop g5 he
can I thought might be three might be an
idea threatening on c5 he sir eyeing the
device quail he might try to get his get
his night to 2d height as well but I try
to get rid of my bad bishop first and
then put the knight on d4 threatening
night h3 the question is if it is a
three threat though the night so the
rookie is a very stupid looking piece in
this position that is even running into
this checker but it's not it's not a big
deal I think I better go to deform as
well as it was planned all along
yeah he's got knight on d5 as well but i
will try to get player on the Kings side
if he takes I have the check I'm in with
the pond I have to check Queen g3 the
rook is singing check so maybe this
search the check wasn't good yeah okay
rook g1 Queenie six if I think a
weakness I've happening to take it
actually because of the rock d 1
hmm I'm wondering about it looks like G
5pm that this may be too drastic if he
goes at five look at five it's probably
crazy right oh come on you need to risk
some otherwise you never get get
anything going yes I felt him taking the
rook let's the letter for checked
now very tricky position I think I'll
just get the pawn and this would be a
huge accomplishment it's some important
than taking unit here just just take it
now or is he meeting me or something on
the G file I don't I don't see anything
special ok I'm to h6 let's cover the
pawn if we attack sit with Queen d2
friends since i have rookie form and i'm
just threatening to push it and he
cannot get the Queen into play I think
and this should be the decisive decisive
factor
Queen age 3 mmm not sure
I can even play Rob g3 maybe look f3
coming hmm ninite a three-year now
Knight f3 yeah threatening queen age 2 +
91 white forfeits on time okay I had
this look look quite ok I believe yeah
this um this is an interesting structure
that we got here around here come on
this structure i mean this at first
looks really some problems here this at
first looks a bit questionable for black
because of the bad bishop but the
important thing is that you have this d
foursquare and you managed to get your
night in there this is no big deal and I
managed to get the rid of the night at
the bishop beam with with this move yeah
and maybe why should just just stay put
here not player for I think efforts of
course the move you yeah you want to
play you want to play active moves but
it is weakening i'm not i'm not sure
about that and in fact it's better
because of quid a for the computer just
wants to take the pawn yeah you can do
it i mean there's no made threat or
something this is too bad this is the
best proof i didn't consider that at all
i mean i think also here this is quite
ok for black guy i just have the
initiative g5 was a bit bit risky but
seems ok yeah he cracked under under the
pressure simply with a little time on
the clock around here this gets very
very problematic already okay thanks for
watching